welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of The Last
of Us episode 7 which adapts the Left
Behind DLC of the games exploring
Ellie's backstory with Riley as they
explore the four to five wonders of them
all which somehow didn't include natural
wonders remember that store it's where a
sensitive kids went because we were too
soft for Spencer's Gifts let's break
this down scene by scene for the details
you missed in the connections to the
game and a reminder to subscribe to our
new channel the Deep dive and you can
support our growing Network by grabbing
some merch at nerdright.shop like this
last of us inspired shirt I love it so
much okay so the episode opens from the
point of view of someone sliding on the
ground past these suburban houses we see
a trail of blood in the snow and then
inside Joel's sleeping bag with rope
Blood Stained showing how Ellie had her
horse drag Joel on the sleeping bag
through the street meaning we were
opening from Joel's point of view as is
being dragged this poor horse has to
shake some snow off its head Ellie
didn't even have time to thaw it out
Joel tells Ellie that she should leave
him and go north to Tommy they're in the
basement of this house which based on
the broken end windows on the ground
level might be the warmest place in
there Ellie pauses at the top of the
stairs and then we edit under grabbing
the doorknob she's not slowly leaving in
defeat she's still in a hurry she's
rushing to find supplies to save Joel
now the Left Behind DLC shows this
moment in the game and in the game you
really intercut from the flashback to
the present as Ellie scrambling to find
supplies in the pharmacy to save Joel
here the president events actually just
book in the episode but here we flash
back to Ellie a few weeks before we met
her in episode 1 as Ellie adventurous
School runs in gym class listening to a
Walkman playing Pearl Jam's all or none
it's from the 2002 album Riot Act which
came out just a year before outbreak day
in 2003 and would have been one of the
most recent and moodiest things a kid
could listen to right now Eddie vedder's
lyrics are it's a hopeless situation and
I'm starting to believe that this
hopeless situation is what I'm trying to
achieve Ellie feels hopeless in this
federal system and is starting to think
this is actually just what she's trying
to achieve a mean girl Bethany Yanks off
Ellie's headphone and Bethany is around
and about to find out saying that Ellie
doesn't fight it's her friend who fights
for her and her friends not around and I
love how the song comes back despite
Ellie not putting her headphones back on
showing how she is mentally
transitioning back into that hopeless
headspace and doesn't give a [__] now
throughout this the overhead lights in
the gym are flickering a bit showing how
Phedra hasn't really set up a good
infrastructure in the Boston qz Phedra
cannot truly promise the light only the
fireflies can Ellie punches Bethany we
cut to her with her head back black eye
make it look like she really knocked
herself out with a punch outside this
office we can hear seagulls just a nice
acoustic effect reminding us that we're
back in Boston Captain Quang is a framed
photo of his family little example of
federal officers being a bit humanized
which is why Ellie reacts so strongly
against Riley's freedom fighting AKA
terrorism Quang tells Ellie and that'll
be your life from now until you catch a
bullet from a firefly or fall drunk off
a roof or get your hair caught in a
moving tank tread get your hair caught
in a tank tread has this happened before
yikes he uses his mug to represent One
path and his keys with a puppy print to
represent the federal path one
representing a food ration soup that
you'd get in a handout another
representing active access to a vehicle
or a resonance an Open Door Quang tells
her fedra is the only thing keeping it
from falling apart but says there's a
leader in you and one day it could be
your turn yes the one piece of actual
valuable advice he leaves Ellie with
because Ellie will in this episode with
Joel have to step up as the leader in
Ellie's dorm we see dinosaurs and a
lunar chart and space shuttle drawings
again Ellie is fascinated by space
travel and sadly [__] ride and the
book no pun intended the first volume by
Will Livingston this otter be good and
on her walls as opposed to the 2000
movie red planet and behind her bed a
poster for the 1987 Dennis Quaid film
interspace Ellie reads an issue of
savage Starlight this is Issue Number
Eight Negan trippy described as with
Captain Ryan's leadership and daniela's
technological expertise the raids of the
last watch have become ever more daring
as a scientist can she bear to use her
gifts for Destruction you actually find
this issue later in the game in the
Lakeside Resort on a green bench the
part of the game that we will likely see
next episode the pages Ellie reads here
show Captain Ryan and Daniela blasting
through a door but keep in mind that
description I mentioned the idea of a
doctor using their gifts of science for
Destruction I'll talk about that a bit
more in spoiler corner on Ellie his
nightstand is her switchblade the one
given to her by her mother and around
the room as she sleeps we see cassette
tapes for Etta James in the hits of aha
aha's Take On Me Later plays in the mall
the song has a major significance to
both Joel and Ellie in the games there's
also a poster for Mortal Kombat 2 the
game that they'll play in the mall
arcade and was referenced by Ellie back
in episode 3. now there is an empty bed
in her room in the Left Behind DLC Riley
comments how Ellie's lucky for still not
having a roommate in the bunk bed above
her and here Riley sneaks in and puts
her hand over Ellie's mouth in the game
Riley jumps in and bites her neck
pretending to be infected foreshadowing
both of these girls getting bitten this
episode Riley confesses that she has
joined the fireflies simply by showing
Ellie her gun in the game Riley shows
Ellie her tag necklace but it's
interesting how the gun is enough for
Ellie to know that she's telling the
truth because there's no other way Riley
would be able to get a gun as they make
their way out in the night La mentions a
7-Eleven incident that burnt off one of
her eyebrows which explains why part of
her left eyebrow is cinched off no
thanks I put to keep my other eyebrow on
one piece Ellie's flashlight glitches
Firefly lights are better just a
reminder of that Firefly Creed when
you're lost in the darkness look for the
light they climb seven flights of stairs
climbing way too many flights of stairs
as Ellie will do with Joel and KC and
they find this guy who odied on pills
and booze now the game you actually get
alcohol from the tent of their friend
Winston Winston was the guy who taught
Ellie how to ride a horse but we don't
meet Winston here this is just an
anonymous corpse at first it looks like
it's cordyceps coming out of his mouth
but it's not it's just chunks of vomit
from what he threw up from OD and he
falls through a cartoonishly perfect
hole in the floor Ellie asks Riley is
that the first dead body you ever saw no
my parents
yeah sorry I I know I mean I knew that
yes Riley's backstory is that when she
was young her dad got infected and tore
her mother to shreds and so Riley was
forced to kill her dad to survive Riley
lets Ellie hold her gun and it looks
like this is the first time Ellie has
handled a pistol which gives greater
significance to Ellie cradling that
pistol back in episode 4 when she kissed
it in that moment she was remembering
Riley they make it to the Liberty
Gardens shopping center this is the mall
in the games where Ellie and Riley goof
around in Riley explains that when
Ventra connected the nearby block to
expand the residences the mall lights
came on too which allows Riley to get
Ellie this wonderful gift Ellie's fed
her flashlight flickers off and so this
Firefly gives Ellie the gift of light as
each row of stores lights up like a
Christmas tree compared to the game it
actually seems like Riley did a lot more
to plan out this night for Ellie rather
than it just being a gift of them going
to the mall together Riley planned out a
schedule for Ellie aha's Take On Me
plays which in addition to its
significance to Ellie and Joel later in
the games it also is just a great 80s
song playing in a shopping mall shopping
malls are kind of a symbolic rite of
passage it's for kids who grew up in the
80s now in front of the cinema it's a
movie poster dawn of the wolf this is a
fictional movie series in the games
meant to parody Twilight and Twilight
Breaking Dawn Joel's Diner Sarah
actually had a dawn of the wolf poster
in her bedroom in the game and you'll
notice in the box office there's a
poster for a Bill Murray Scarlett
Johansson movie This Is Lost to
translation which has a tagline everyone
wants to be found which of course also
really applies to Ellie on this journey
also it's interesting how in all of the
lootings someone took the time to tag
this LensCrafters ad with luscious
lipstick and the woman in the spirit to
be missing a tooth this was either Riley
herself or the Cyclops from Shrek III
who rips stamps off letters see I
remember all messy chaos [__] they
wonder why anyone would ever wear
Victoria's Secret lingerie and Riley
says she imaginelli wearing it making
her laugh but you can see how this
flatters Ellie a bit she fixes her hair
in the glass reflection and her face
floats over one of those mannequin busts
there is just something about shopping
malls with those Abercrombie bags that
sexually activates every team for
teenage Eric it was the Unicorn wind
chimes and natural wonders the shirts at
Hot Topic were just too aggressive as
they do in the game they find a carousel
one of my favorite moments in the game
because you stay in Ellie's point of
view as the mall spins around you but
this Carousel has an interesting song no
way yeah
foreign
this is a version of the cures 1987 Just
Like Heaven but a Rock-a-bye Baby
lullaby rendition of cure songs thus the
Dollhouse music box instrumentation I
know I've never ridden a carousel with a
music Taste Of The Duffer Brothers But
Here we are now according to the Cure
lead singer Robert Smith Just Like
Heaven is quote about hyperventilating
kissing and fainting to the floor Smith
said the opening line of the song show
me show me show me how you do that trick
refers to his childhood memories of
Mastery magic tricks but he added quote
on another level it's about a seduction
trick from much later in my life and
this song reflects how Riley is taking
Ellie's breath away with these magical
gifts but let's remember 80s songs are
this Show's code for danger ahead and
while Ellie rides a fake or sahir her
true destiny is beyond this to ride an
actual horse a horse that she forgets to
brush the snow off of Riley reveals that
Quan gave her sewage detail which is the
worst assignment but remember this is a
gig that Joel took in episode 1 because
it paid the best if things had gone
differently Riley would have been
supervising Joel Now The Last of Us
makes it clear the apocalypse is gross
there are tendrils coming out of mouths
I can't handle this but you know we can
hold ourselves to a higher standard of
hygiene thanks to quit quit quip so quip
makes keeping your mouth healthy easy
equipped electric toothbrush has timed
Sonic vibrations with 30 second pulses
to guide a dentist recommended two
minute clean oh
cleaner
oh don't mind me I just got caught in a
duet with my quick toothbrush this
toothbrush is the Ellie to my Joel I
save this toothbrush and this toothbrush
saves my teeth they also have a water
flosser they can give you a gentle or
deep clean at the touch of a button and
quips gum starter kit fits in just about
any purse or pocket or on the go with
dental health and quip has a special
deal running now for fans of the last of
us but it involves a tough choice you
gotta choose between Joel and Ellie to
cast your vote in the quip apocalypse go
did once you're there cast your vote by
using either Joel or Ellie as your promo
code either code will automatically get
you 20 off any quip water flosser that's
this guy with toothbrush or the gum
starter kit but if your favorite
character ends up getting the most votes
whip will send you a special power up to
help fight off the black monster which
is like a bloater that lives in your
mouth so make sure to get your votes in
before midnight on March 8th we'll
announce the winner on the finale
breakdown so again that's getquip.com
infected and use the promo codes Joel or
Ellie to vote for your favorite
character Riley eyes the photo booth and
Ellie asks is that a time machine come
on in a way a photo booth is a sort of
metaphorical time machine a booth that
freezes its occupants in time with a
string of photos in the game this photo
booth prompts Ellie and Riley to share
the photos on Facebook and they have no
idea what Facebook is and then after
retrying it again again Riley just
punches it until it shuts down but this
screen inside the booth shows a white
rabbit wearing sunglasses in last week's
breakdown I pointed out how the hunted
White Rabbit that Ellie steals parallels
her own innocent self LED comes the
rabbit here when they give each other
bunny ears and they end by pretending to
be monsters like the infected forms they
become or at least one of them becomes
because though Ellie doesn't know it yet
she is immune this photo film does not
print fully likely because the film has
been partially exposed or maybe the
chemicals have just started to break
down rasha's arcade sign looks exactly
as it does in the game and the name Raja
is actually a naughty dog reference to
another big Naughty Dog franchise
Uncharted the characters Eddie Raja and
Rico Raja and the street signs an
Uncharted 2 among Thieves for The
Nepalese club club Raja but instead of
the fake in Universe games these are all
real games that kids who hung out in
arcades in 2003 would remember you got
your Tetris your Frogger an attack from
Mars pinball machine Daytona USA all
that's really missing is Dance Dance
Revolution Time Crisis 2 some House of
the Dead But yep we do get Mortal Kombat
2 which Ellie referenced with Molina in
episode three in the game there are some
fighter games like tetsu Mushu
tournament and fighter Instinct 10 but
there's also a game called the turning
that you actually play in the game
though Riley makes Ellie close her eyes
so you just see Ellie's face while you
hit the controls not really knowing what
is on the screen now the name the
Turning was actually based on Neil
druckman's original title of The Last of
Us comics when he pitched it to naughty
dog to be a game and I love it when they
drop the coins in to start the game
Craig Mason actually said that he told
the sound mixers to really go hard on
the game sounds on the game start sound
effect with heavy bass just to surround
us with the feeling of playing one of
these arcade games
[Music]
in this game of Mortal Kombat 2 Ellie
picks Raiden excellent choice Riley
picks Molina and since Ellie doesn't get
any hits on her it is a Flawless Victory
which is why Riley says Flawless
horseshit and Bradley gets to do
Melina's Kiss of Death fatality that
Ellie described in episode 3 where he
spit out the bones but yes this does
mirror the kiss of death that infected
perform on their victims and tried to do
on Ellie in this episode we slowly pull
back out of the arcade and then we move
to what was already the most terrifying
story in any mall before the apocalypse
the American Girl doll shop every story
has a star horse is Winnie because
they're always scared and here the
Runner comes alive and if this guy was
hanging out in an American Girl Doll
shop what kind of monster was he to
begin with do you really have a daughter
sir or is this for you I mean I don't
want a toy shame but just grab some
attack of the Clones Dooku lightsabers
over at KB Toys I know in this breakdown
you're learning a lot about 2003 era
Mall air and Justin he smelled way worse
than this guy did so Ellie now picks
Baraka for the second round and she wins
doing baraka's fatality finishing move
on Molina and this is almost a moment
where the girls kiss but Riley moves on
and that triggers Ellie to want to back
out and go home but Riley lures her in
to stay with the promise of a gift will
Livingston's no pun intended volume 2.
what did the frustrated cannibal do
laid on me he threw up his hands
[Music]
it's here that it will cover in spoiler
corner but then Ellie reads
um how does a computer get drunk
it takes screenshots
what are screenshots I don't actually
know yes like the Facebook confusion in
the game in a world that shuts down in
2003 there's no way these girls are
gonna get Tech references but Ellie
finds Riley's Firefly bombs what do you
call an alligator in a vest
foreign don't get the answer but the
answer is an investigator as Ellie is
now investigating this crime scene and
if you like investigations and don't
mind puns too much you really should
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive one actually wonders if one of
these pipe bombs was the one that was
used on the building Tess was in back in
episode one so Ellie's Federal
indoctrination makes her disgusted to
find these bombs and Riley says that
she's leaving to the Atlanta QC now we
only ever hear of the Atlantic QC in the
games in the Pittsburgh section when the
Atlanta QC takes command over
Pittsburgh's remaining Federal forces
suggesting Atlanta is a key Federal
stronghold which would make sense
considering in real life that is where
the CDC is headquartered and I played
the tabletop game pandemic Legacy season
one and I let the city of Atlanta
outbreak in the first month and I lost
my starter research station which really
made Atlanta very important place than
any pandemic post-apocalypse Riley said
Marlene would let Riley take Ellie with
her suggesting Marley had her eye on
Ellie and didn't want her to leave the
Boston Q Z Ellie storms off and decides
to go back and for a second we think
tragedy is already struck with the sound
of a scream but it is just a Halloween
decoration great fake out I thought you
would like this one the best so I saved
it now in the game this costume shop is
actually one of the first places they go
to and they move around wearing these
same masks as they do here Riley wearing
the clown mask Ellie wearing the
werewolf mask though in the game they
switched to a witch mask Riley says I
don't know what it was like to have a
family
to belong it's kind of hurtful thing to
say but Ellie doesn't take offense
because rightly it's right Riley suffers
more because she remembers her family
and will always need to belong to some
family like Tommy she is a joiner Ellie
and Joel were both colder before they
met each other but upon forming this
familial partnership that love makes
them more vulnerable with this Show's
creators call the toxicity of
unconditional love Riley plays Ellie's
other tape cassette that we saw earlier
Etta James I Got You Babe the arguably
lesser known but definitely better
version compared to the sunny and Cher
version this Etta James I Got You Babe
also plays in Left Behind game Ellie
asks Riley not to go Riley says okay and
they kiss yet like Melina's Kiss of
Death and All Pure Love in this story it
is a deadly force the angriest American
Girl dad plows through the store and as
he grabs Ellie if you look closely
already
starting to reach out of his mouth this
Runner is literally wearing Nike just do
it track pants so he may have actually
been a bit athletic before getting
infected though I don't know a lot of
guys in Boston will wear Nike gear
doesn't mean they're fit but this guy's
particularly hard to take down Ellie
stabs him in the side a few times but
that's no good she has to stab him
through the brain to take him down Riley
at this point already knows she's been
bitten by the time Ellie's celebrating
which is why she doesn't celebrate with
her she's already come to terms with her
fate but it crushes her even more when
she notices Ellie's bite and notice how
Riley stayed in front of a haunted
forest backdrop with a ghostly form at
the bottom of it tragic irony given her
current fate it's interesting that we
cut directly from this no Fade to Black
no bumper transition right to Joel
trembling back on the floor in the
present this abrupt edit makes it seem
like Joel is in the same place as they
are like that dead runner on the floor
has turned into him both of them with
stab wounds in their sides and for Ellie
mentally these moments are merged she
lost Riley and so she's determined not
to lose Joel too like Captain Kwong
Riley presents two options the quick and
painless option suicide or the one in
which they do not quit they just last as
long as they can before they turn turn
the fact that they choose losing their
minds together is what saves Ellie
because had they decided to prematurely
end it Ellie never would have discovered
her immunity and so after some good
old-fashioned Last of Us drawer
searching Ellie finds exactly what she
needs a needle and thread to stitch Joel
back up and so she finally gave herself
an option three by stepping up as a
leader to save the partner she loves
okay on the spoiler Corner that joke
about cannibals yup gotta be a nod to
the group of cannibals Ellie's about to
meet next week led by David and that
Savage Starlight issue about a scientist
using their gifts for Destruction big
spoiler if you have not played part one
of the game coming up here I think that
is setting up the ethical dilemma that
we will face in the finale when the
doctors at St Mary's in Salt Lake City
intend to operate on Ellie to remove the
cordyceps from her brain an operation
that could save Humanity but will kill
Ellie unless Joel intervenes to stop it
and yes it adds a deeper layer of tragic
subtext to have Ellie and Riley
listening to aha's Take On Me
considering that will be the song that
Ellie plays on guitar for Dina her
future girlfriend assuming they adapt
season two from two with a game okay
reminder to subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive and you can support us by
grabbing some merch at nerdrive.shop
like this last of us look for the light
shirt and if you want me to cover it
back up this huckberry jacket is also
awesome super warm and you can grab one
of these by clicking the link in the
description follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at avos follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
foreign